also abend ist überzeugte sich das
moderne also das totalitäre böse mit
traditionellen philosophischen
begrifflichkeiten nicht mehr angemessen
beschreiben lässt zurzeit ihre
totalitarismus studie die 51 erschienen
verwendet sie zwar noch immer den
begriff des radikal bösen und klub somit
an cantz konzeption an
dennoch deutete sie diesen begriff schon
hier völlig anders als kann
doch besonders berühmt und berüchtigt
ist abend nicht wegen ihres begriffs des
radikal bösen geworden sondern wegen
ihrer späteren konzeption der banalität
des bösen die sie aufgrund des eichmann
prozesses entwickelt hat obwohl meine
überzeugung nach abends begriff des
vertical bösen und und ihre phrase die
beiden die banalität des bösen nicht
sehr weit auseinander liegen sondern
viel mehr der selbe phänomen aus zwei
verschiedenen perspektiven die der taten
und die des täters beschreiben werde ich
mich in meiner heutigen interpretation
primär auf abends begriff der banalität
des bösen fokussieren also der ausflug
die banalität des bösen hebt andere
aspekte des bösen hervor
als die ältere definition nach abends
meinung
aus diesem grund so meine meinung ist
eine neue philosophische aufarbeitung
dieses begriffs wichtig weil sie
einerseits auf relevante unterschiede zu
den traditionellen auffassungen des
bösen verweist und weil sie uns
andererseits hilft die banalität des
bösen nicht nur geschichtlich politisch
sondern auch philosophisch theoretisch
zu erfassen
dennoch hat aden selbst nie eine theorie
des bösen wirklich entwickelt und sich
hat auch kein systematisches werk dazu
geschrieben obwohl die
auseinandersetzung mit dem begriff des
bösen ohne zweifel im mittelpunkt ihres
nachdenkens steht aber auch wenn sie
keine philosophische theorien zum bösen
auferlegt hat ist sie in ihrer arbeit
auf die suche nach einer neuen
definition des bösen die wichtigen
philosophischen ansätze dazu finden sich
insbesondere in ihrem letzten
unvollendeten und posthum erschienenen
buch vom leben des geistes ebenso wie
ihn dann ebenso posthum erschienenen
vorlesungen zum bösen
sie aber damals an der new school for
social research 65 new york gehalten hat
also die beiden werke werden wir
deswegen zur grundlage beim einer
philosophischen rekonstruktion dieses
begriffs urbanität des bösen dienen
meine these dass abend mit ihrer deutung
der banalität des bösen auf der spur
einer neuen definition des bösen ist
möchte ich durch die charakterisierung
des banalen bösen als eines
monologischen bösen weiter erläutern und
begründen
mit dem begriff des monologischen will
ich auf einen denken verweisen dass ich
nicht als sein zwiegespräch mit sich
selbst konzipieren ist also nicht das
monolog als ein inneres dialog sondern
als ein denken das zwar immer noch einen
gedankengang darstellt aber trotzdem
kein wirkliches tätiges kritisches und
theologisches denken ist das ist es
meiner meinung nach was atmet meinen
wenn sie die banalität des bösen mit der
gedankenlosigkeit verbindet
gedankenlosigkeit beschreibt einen
zustand in dem kein wirkliches
nachdenken vorhanden ist
durch das monologischen der banalität
lässt sich auf die grundlegende
unterschiede zwischen abend begriff und
den traditionellen auffassungen
verweisen und somit lässt sich auch die
neuheit dieses begriffs herausstellen
wie später zeigen beide gehen die
klassischen definition des bösen immer
aus einer spaltung im willen hervor
während für abends pendelt dieses bösen
gerade die aufhebung jeglicher spaltung
sei es im will oder ihm denken
charakteristisch ist
weil die freie entscheidung für das böse
und für das gute normalerweise als ein
kampf zwischen zwei alternativen
aufgepasst wird zum beispiel zwischen
sinnlichkeit und vernunft besetzen wir
im bezug zum wählen sie begriffen diese
spaltung immer schon voraus
doch durch diese analyse der bestimmung
gegründetes willens lässt sich das
spezifische der banalität des bösen
nicht mehr erklären weil für das banal
böse gerade das manko jeglicher spaltung
charakteristisch ist
um den begriff der banalität des bösen
deswegen weiter erläutern zu können
wendet sich deshalb abend in ihrem opus
der analyse der geistes tätigkeiten
neben dem willen vor allem dann im
denken und im urteilen und in meiner
präsentation werde ich deswegen abends
begriff der banalität des bösen
in bezug zu ihrer analyse der geistes
tätigkeiten behandeln deswegen ist für
meine interpretation auch nicht die
frage zentral ob ihre bezeichnung in
bezug auf eichmann angemessen ist mir
geht es primär nicht um eine konkrete
historisch politische analyse der nazi
verbrecher sondern um eine philosophisch
theoretische rekonstruktion dieses
begriffs der am ende auch eine breitere
philosophisch theoretische relevanz
haben könnte dennoch begründet abend in
der einleitung zum buch vom leben des
geistes ihr interesse für die drei
tätigkeiten des geistes denken wollen
und urteil gerade mit dem anstoß der ihr
der eigenen prozess gegeben hat trotzdem
versuchte sie aber in jedem buch keine
theorie oder thesen zur über das böse zu
entwickeln also dass eichmann buch
selbst ist ein bericht zum prozess und
keine philosophische studien doch sie
ahnt es schon damals dass ihre
formulierung die banalität des bösen
unserer literarischen wie sie sagt
theologischen und philosophischen
denktradition über das böse
entgegenläuft
aufgrund dieser vielversprechenden
einleitung zum buch vom leben des
geistes wo sie auf die problematik des
bösen reguliert könnte man glauben dass
die philosophische behandlung des bösen
in ihrem letzten buch im mittelpunkt
stehen wird doch dies ist eigentlich
nicht der fall
die auseinandersetzung mit dem bösen
stellt zwar den wichtigsten antrieb für
ihre erneute beschäftigung mit der
geistes tätigkeiten da aber zu einer
klaren philosophischen verknüpfung
zwischen diesen geistes tätigkeiten
einerseits und der problematik des bösen
andererseits kommen sie auch in diesem
buch nicht
trotzdem lässt sich nicht übersehen dass
ich abend in dieser in dieser analyse
begibt um am ende auch ihre bedeutung
des bösen besser erläutern zu können
deswegen ist die hauptintention ihres
buches meiner meinung nach dennoch auch
mit dem versuch einer weiteren
theoretisch philosophischen konzept
realisierung des bösen verbunden
ich werde jetzt zuerst auf die
wichtigsten unterschiede zwischen abends
begriff und ihrem verständnis der
traditionellen auffassungen des bösen
verweisen schon in ihrem buch elemente
und ursprünge totaler herrschaft also in
dieser totalitarismus studie wo sie sich
noch auf den begriff des radikal bösen
bezieht weil sie darauf hin
dass sich das totalitäre böse nicht mehr
durch böse oder sündige motive erklären
lässt und diese charakterisierung bleibt
auch für die banalität des bösen zentral
ich lese ein zitat von abend ist
schreibt das böse hat sich als sehr
radikaler erwiesen als vorgesehen
äußerlich gesprochen die modernen
verbrechen sind im dekalog nicht
vorgesehen oder die abendländische
tradition krankt an dem vorurteil dass
das böseste was der mensch tun kann
aus den lastern der selbstsucht same
stammt während wir wissen dass das
böseste oder das radikal böse mit
solchen menschlich begreifbaren sündigen
motiven gar nichts mehr zu tun hat also
allen benutzt schon in den 50er jahren
den begriff des radikal bösen nicht um
dadurch die täter zu dämonisieren ganz
im gegenteil das böse ist schon zur zeit
ihrer totalitarismus studie gerade
gerade deswegen radikal weil er sich mit
den eigenen mutigen oder egoistischen
oder überhaupt irgend welchen motiven
nicht mehr erklären lässt und eben
derselbe charakterisierung nämlich die
behauptung dass ich dieses böse nicht
mehr durch böse motive erklären lässt
stellt steht auch in den mittelpunkt
ihrer definition der banalität des bösen
wir sehen ist dieser bruch mit der
traditionellen auffassung des bösen für
abend von anfang an wesentlich mit ihrem
neuen ausdruck die banalität des bösen
will sie das nur noch deutlicher
herausstellen
sie weist in einem brief an schulen
ausdrücklich darauf hin dass dieses böse
zwei extrem ist aber zugleich keine
kiefer hat das ist ein zitat von alt ich
bin in der tat heute der meinung dass
das böse immer nur extrem ist aber
niemals radikal
es hat keine tiefe auch keine dämonie es
kann die ganze welt verwüsten gerade
weil es wie ein bild an der oberfläche
weit weiter wuchert tief aber und
radikal ist immer nur das gute und der
begriff des banal bösen lässt sich somit
weder mit dem dämonischen noch mit dem
egoistischen gleichsetzen
das zitat ein anderes zitat von abend
noch dazu ich habe stand vor etwas
völlig anderem und doch unbestreitbar
wirklichen ich war frappiert von der
offenbaren sagt hey des täters die keine
zur rückführung des unbestreitbaren
lösen seine handlungen auf irgendwelche
tiefen wurzeln oder beweggründe
ermöglichte
die taten waren ungeheuerlich doch der
täter war ganz gewöhnlichen
durchschnittlich weder dämonisch noch
ungeheuerlich negativ lässt sich also
sagen dass für die banalität des bösen
erstes nicht die bösen motive aus
vergeben sind und dass zweitens dieses
böse auch keine teuflisch dämonische
kiefer hat es handelt sich auch also
nicht um einen willen zum bösen wenn sie
über die banalität des bösen spricht das
problem des bösen als banal des bösen
muss viel mehr mit unserem denkvermögen
zusammenhängen wie sie sagt und sie
schreibt zum beispiel in dem buch vom
leben des geistes dieses fehlen des
denkens eine durchaus normale erfahrung
im alltagsleben wo wir kaum zeit
geschweige denn die neigung haben
innezuhalten und nachzudenken er rief
mein interesse wach ist böses handeln
unterlassung sowie auch begehung sünden
möglich wenn nicht nur niedrige motive
wie es im rechtswesen heißt fehlen
sondern überhaupt jedes motiv jede
spezielle aktivität des interesses oder
wollens ist bloß halt wie immer man sie
definieren mörder ist diese wille zum
bösen vielleicht keine notwendige
bedingung des börsenhandels hängt
vielleicht vielleicht das problem von
gut und böse
unsere fähigkeit recht und unrecht zu
unterscheiden mit unserem denkvermögen
zusammen fraktion denn der abend und an
und versucht sie ihr versuchten die
banalität des bösen
gerade als eine besondere art der
gedankenlosigkeit aufzufassen sie
schreibt weiter wenn etwas richtiges an
dem oben von mir geäußerten gedanken
sein sollte dass die fähigkeit recht und
unrecht zu unterscheiden etwas mit dem
denkvermögen zu tun habe dann müssten
wir ihre anwendung von jedem normalen
menschen verlangen können
gleichgültig wie gebildet oder unwissend
intelligent oder dumm eher zufällig ist
gedankenlosigkeit ist nicht dumm hat sie
findet sich auch bei hoch intelligenten
menschen und ihre ursache ist nicht ein
schlechtes herz wahrscheinlich kann
umgekehrt schlechtigkeit durch
gedankenlosigkeit entstehen so
beschreibt sie also die problematik des
bösen in der einleitung zum buch vom
leben des geistes doch soviel
versprechen wie diese einleitung auch
klingen
im buch selbst findet sich kaum noch
etwas explizit zu diesem thema die zwei
folgende teile über das denken und das
wohl den dritten teil zum urteil könnte
sie nicht mehr zu ende schreiben
wir setzen sich kaum noch direkt mit dem
problem des bösen auseinander
trotzdem denke ich das ist aufgrund
dieses dass es aufgrund dieses buches
und mit der unterstützung ihrer früheren
vorlesungen zum bösen aus dem jahr 560
dennoch möglich ist eine sozusagen
theorie der bei der banalität des bösen
zu rekonstruieren und ich komme jetzt zu
meiner interpretation des monologischen
bei dieser banalität des bösen also für
eine weitere für weitere erläuterung des
begriffs der banalität des bösen ist
abends beschreibung des denkens als
eines zwiegesprächs mit sich selbst von
besonderer bedeutung
auf diese weise lässt sich das denken
immer schon als ein dialog aufzupassen
und abend veranschaulicht dies
insbesondere in bezug zu sokrates und zu
seinem verständnis des denkens die erste
bedingung dafür dass das individuum als
eine moralische persönlichkeit fungieren
kann ist verbunden mit unserer fähigkeit
zu denken und dabei im gespräch mit uns
selbst zu sein
auch das selbstgespräch somit eine art
des dialogs nur wenn wir in der lage
sind ein zwiegespräch mit uns selbst zu
führen können wir am ende auch in
harmonie mit uns selbst sein und als
einer also als einer person fungieren
diese harmonie verlangen deshalb keine
komplette komplette einstimmigkeit
sondern die möglichkeit sich als zwei in
einem zu begreifen und somit im dialog
mit sich selbst zu sein
nur aufgrund der ursprünglichen spaltung
lässt sich überhaupt über eine
übereinstimmung mit sich selbst sprechen
insofern ist auch dass waffe denken
immer ein innerer dialog und kein
monolog auch die literarischen monologe
sind in diesem sinne er ihn als innere
dialoge rovers und auch so gedacht dass
behauptung dass es besser ist unrecht zu
leiden als unrecht zu tun die sehr
wichtig für abend ist somit eine folge
dieser natur des denkens wenn man
unrecht tut ist man nämlich laut hat es
nicht mehr in übereinstimmung mit sich
selbst und das bedeutet mit sich selbst
uneins zu sein und das will man nicht
sein
der abend ist dieser behauptung von
sokrates sehr wichtig
und sie interpretieren sie auch
ausführlich sie schreibt wenn ich
unrecht tue bin ich dazu verdammt in
unerträglicher intimität mit einem
unrecht tourenden zusammenzuleben
ich kann ihn nie loswerden das
verbrechen also das den augen der bürger
und menschen verborgen bleibt ein
verbrechen das überhaupt nicht
erscheinen weil es niemanden gibt der es
erscheint existiert eigentlich nicht so
wie ich mein eigener partner bin wenn
ich denke bin ich mein eigener zeuge
wenn ich handle
ich kenne den täter und bin dazu
verdammt mit ihm zusammenzuleben und
deswegen fungiert der dialog zuerst der
innere dialog mit uns selbst bei
sokrates als die grundlage für das
moralisch auf und abends zieht ihr
darüber auch eine stelle aus platons
dialog burgas wohl sorgt er sagt und ich
wenigstens bin der meinung dass liebe
auch meine lehrer verstimmt sein und
misstönen möge oder ein core den ich an
zu führen hätte und die meisten menschen
nicht mit mir einstimmen sondern mir
wieder sprechen mögen also dass sich
allein mit mir selbst nicht zusammen
stimmen sondern mehr widersprechen
müssten müssen müsste art interpretiert
also so gehört es als jemanden der zum
ausgangspunkt seiner moral theorie diese
einstimmigkeit mit sich selbst nimmt
ich der ich einer bin stellt diese
grundlage für das moralische da aber ich
kann als einer nur dann fungieren wenn
ich nicht schlicht einer bin und abend
interpretiert deswegen sogar das
erfolgen der weise sie sagt da etwas
gemeinde ist klar selbst wenn ich ein
ich einer bin bin ich nicht schlicht
einer vielmehr habe ich einen selbst und
stehe zu diesem selbst aus meinem
eigenen selbst in beziehung und deswegen
dieses verhältnis mit mir selbst kein
monologischen verhältnis sondern kann es
nur als ein biologisches verhältnis
fungieren moral basiert somit zuerst auf
einer spannung und möglichkeit der
disharmonie so lange als man im dialog
mit sich selbst steht besucht man die
harmonie und kämpft man gegen die
disharmonie und gerade das bedeutet für
ein für abend 1 2 in einem zu sein
diese dualität verstehen sie auch als
ausgangspunkt für die pluralität des
menschen
sie sagt zb wir würden sagen überall wo
es eine mehrzahl von lebewesen von
dingen von ideen
gibt da ist unterschied und dieser kommt
nicht von außen sondern ist in jedem
gegenstand in form der dualität
enthalten
woraus die einheit als vereinigung
entsteht also alle geistes tätigkeiten
sind auf diese spaltung angewiesen wie
abend auch sehr deutlich darstellen
sie schreibt weiter die geistigen
tätigkeiten und wie wir später sehen
werden vor allem das denken dass das
stumme zwiegespräch dass ich mit sich
selbst lassen sich aufpassen als die
aktualisierung der ursprünglichen
dualität oder spaltung zwischen mir und
mir die allem bewusstsein innewohnt das
leben des geistes in dem ich mich mit
mir selbst umgehen kann laut los sein
es ist aber niemals stumm und es kann
niemals völlig selbst vergessen sein
weil alle seine tätigkeiten reflexiv
sind doch sobald es these dass es besser
sei unrecht zu leiden als umwelt zu tun
hat nur dann bestand wenn wir
voraussetzen können dass alle menschen
das bedürfnis haben die dinge
durchzusprechen und dass alle menschen
mit sich selbst sprechen können die
banalität des bösen hingegen aber setzt
gerade diese elementare bedingung nicht
mehr voraus und dadurch zeichnet sich
jetzt schon deutlich auf wieso sich die
banalität des bösen als ein manko dieses
widerspruchs also als ein schweigender
monolog sozusagen verstehen lässt nur
wenn ich als mensch überhaupt nicht im
dialog mit mir selbst denn kann ich
meine eigenen unstimmigkeit gegenüber
indifferent sein und nur dann kann mich
nicht stören wenn ich unrecht tue
menschen die weder mit sich selbst noch
mit den anderen im dialog stehen bemühen
sich überhaupt nicht guter
gesprächspartner zu sein und in diesem
besonderen fall wohl nur noch die
gedanken seien da sind aber kein ziel
gespräche des denkens mehr werden auch
die bösen und egoistischen motive und
intentionen des täters nicht mehr
aufschlussreich und in diesem bezug für
tagen dann ihren begriff der banalität
des bösen ein
in diesem fall lässt sich dann behaupten
dass die taten zwar ungeheuerlich sind
die täter selbst sind aber ganz
durchschnittlich und überhaupt nicht
besonders dämonisch oder egoistisch doch
selbstverständlich bedeutet das nicht
dass ein solcher täter für seine taten
nicht mehr verantwortlich ist ganz im
gegenteil für adelt ist der wesentliche
bestand
weil unsere menschlichkeit dass wir mit
uns selbst und mit anderen zusammen
leben und kommunizieren können der der
der sich diesem zwiegespräch verweigern
versucht gibt auch die elementare
bedingungen unserer menschlichen
pluralität und zwischen menschlichkeit
auf und deswegen ist die banalität des
bösen viel gefährlicher und extremer als
andere arten des bösen
diese ungeheuerlichkeit der banalität
des bösen hat an und schon von anfang an
immer wieder betont unter anderem auch
schon in ihrem totalitarismus buch zum
beispiel
dort spricht sie über einem alles oder
nichts prinzip dass insbesondere für die
totalitären systeme charakteristisch ist
weil dieses prinzip alle moralische
maßstäbe vernichtet und alle menschen
gleichermaßen überflüssig macht sie
schreibt zb in den totalitarismus buch
hier gibt es weder politische noch
geschichtliche noch einfach moralische
maßstäbe sondern höchstens die
erkenntnis dass es in der modernen
politik um etwas zu gehen scheint worum
es eigentlich in der politik wie wir sie
gewöhnlich verstehen nie gehen dürfte
nämlich um alles oder nichts mit dem
begriff des radikal bösen versucht er
sie damals das böse gerade in bezug zu
diesem totalitären regime zu beschreiben
mit ihrem neuen begriff der banalität
des bösen versucht sie aber noch konkret
die menschen und ihre handlungen
aufzupassen und deswegen denke ich nicht
dass ihre konzeption des bösen sich
wegen des eichmann prozesses verändert
hat vielmehr hat sich nur die
perspektive verschoben
unter dem begriff der banalität des
bösen versucht sie jetzt die täter
selbst zu charakterisieren
wegen dieser eigenschaften lässt sich
die banalität des bösen nicht mehr
primär in bezug zu den bösen willen oder
zum egoistischen motiven beschreiben
sondern stellt in erster linie ein manko
des dialogischen selbst selbst gesprächs
war und auch die unfähigkeit sich in die
andere zu versetzen und sie mit
besichtigen ist eine folge dieses manko
dieser monologischen banalität ist dass
die einerseits banal ist aber
andererseits auch viel gefährlicher als
alle andere arten des bösen haben
verbindet sie auch mit einem
realitätsverlust denken selbst wird zu
einem blinden nicht reflektierte
mechanismus gemacht der nie hinterfragt
wird und er sich auch nicht an der
realität messen das nennen also das
nicht nachdenken und hinterfragen fallen
ebenso weg wie das erinnern habe ich
noch eine passage über das erinnern und
fragen sie schreibt diese frage nach der
erinnerung bringt uns mindestens einen
kleinen schritt der quälenden frage nach
der natur des bösen er die philosophie
und auch wie ich zuvor bemerkte die
große literatur kennen den schurken nur
als jemanden der verzweifelt ist und
dessen verzweiflung in mit einem
gewissen adel umgibt ich will nicht
leugnen dass das dass diese type des
übeltäters existiert bin aber sicher
dass die größten übel die wir kennen
nicht ihm zuzuschreiben sind der sich
wieder in die augen sehen muss und
dessen fluch es ist dass er nicht
vergessen kann
die größten übeltäter sind jene die sich
nicht erinnern weil sie auf das getane
niemals gedanken verschwendet haben und
ohne erinnerung kann nicht sie
zurückhaltend das denken an vergangene
angelegenheiten bedeutet für menschliche
wesen sich in die dimension der tiefer
zu begehen wurzeln zu schlagen und so
sich selbst zu stabilisieren so dass man
nicht bei allem möglichen einem
zeitgeist der geschichte oder der
versuchung hinweg geschwemmt wird
das größte böse ist nicht radikal es hat
keine wurzeln und weil es keine wurzeln
hat hat es keine grenzen kann sich ins
unvorstellbare extreme entwickeln und
über die ganze welt ausbreiten
senden dass sie das durch diese
banalität kann man auch im gegen werken
in dem man sich für das stetige
dialogische und reflektieren der denken
entscheidet und dieses zwiegespräch mit
uns selbst liegt nicht nur jedem
richtigen denkens zugrunde sondern dann
auch dem urteilen dieser tätigkeit die
friedenspolitische auch theorie von
besonderer bedeutung war
obwohl ich heute nicht hier getrennt
werden behandelt habe aber schauen wir
uns jetzt am ende noch einmal genauer an
wie so bei der erläuterung der banalität
des bösen die analyse des willens uns
auch nicht weiter hilft vor allem
deswegen ihn nicht denke ich weil die
traditionellen deutungen des bösen immer
noch auf eine art von spaltung
basierende ich hier zwar nicht als ein
zwiegespräch zu nehmen ist sondern eher
als endkämpfen sich selbst wie das auch
aden deutlich beschreibt zum beispiel
indem
buch vom leben des geistes ich schreibe
das wollen die ich für so stellt sich
heraus ist nicht weniger zwiegespalten
als demokratische 2 in einem des
platonischen zwiegesprächs des denkens
doch wie wir bei paulus ahlen pflegen
die beiden teile des wollen denn ich
keineswegs einen friedlichen
harmonischen verkehr miteinander
also dieser spaltung des films
beschreibt abend als einen gnadenlosen
kampf
sie schreibt die spaltung dem willen ist
weit davon entfernt eine friedliche zu
sein
sie kündigt kein zwiegespräch zwischen
mir und mir selbst an sondern einen
gnadenlosen kampf der bis zum tode
andauert im mittelpunkt des willens
punkt problems steht also nach die frage
wie man wie man denn will überreden kann
denn dem diktat der vernunft zu folgen
doch dies zeigt uns deutlich dass der
bildungsbegriff zwei alternative seiten
braucht so wie das schon bei kann
beschrieben worden ist die bestimmung
gründe des willens können entweder im
sinnlichkeit oder in den moralischen
gesetz liegen
ohne diese spannung und zweiseitigkeit
lässt sich das traditionelle form des
bösen nicht verstehen sie schreibt zum
beispiel über kant windes begriff
folgende wenn wir die widersprüche
beiseite lassen und uns nur an das
halten was kann sagen wollte
dann hat er offenbar an einen guten
willen als dem willen gedacht der ja ich
will antwortet wenn ihm so gesagt wird
du sollst anstellt also auch im vermögen
des willens eine die kopie heraus so wie
wir gezeigt haben dass so wie wir
gezeigt haben dass sich die banalität
des bösen vor allem als ein manko des
richtigen selbst gesprächs erfassen
lässt so ist die banalität des bösen
auch auf die spaltung des willens immun
wenn es aber keine spaltung und keine
die foto me gibt die zwischen dem
begehren und der vernunft dann ist dann
ist das daraus resultierende böse auch
nicht eine folge des bösen willens oder
der nicht moralischen motivation und
deswegen bezeichneten die banalität des
bösen als eine art der gedankenlosigkeit
wie keines richtigen zwiegesprächs mit
uns selbst fähig ist weil sich der
individuum verweigert 1 2 in einem zu
sein
aber dieses 2 in einem zu sein und nach
der harmonie mit sich selbst zu stehen
ist die grundlage für ein kritisches
denken und dann auch für ein gelungenes
urteilen
das jetzt nicht nur ein verhältnis mit
sich selbst herstellt sondern auch ein
verhältnis mit der welt ich möchte jetzt
meine präsentation noch mit einem zitat
von abend schließen dass der
grundgedanke grundgedanke ihrer
ausführungen zum bösen noch einmal
deutlich auf den punkt punkt bringt das
ist aus ihrem buch über das böse sie
schreibt ich hoffe dass unsere heutigen
erörterungen verdeutlicht haben warum
ich die frage aufwarf mit wem wir
zusammen sein wollen
ich versuchte zu zeigen dass unsere
entscheidungen über recht und unrecht
von der wahl unserer gesellschaft von
der wahl derjenigen mit denen wir unser
leben zu verbringen wünschen abhängen
werden in dem unwahrscheinlichen
unterscheiden unwahrscheinlichen fall
dass jemand daher kommen könnte und zu
erzählen
er würde gerne mit ritter blaubart
zusammensein in sich also zb wählen ist
das einzige was wir tun können dafür zu
sorgen dass er niemals in unsere nähe
gelangt doch ist so fürchte ich die
wahrscheinlichkeit weitaus größer dass
jemand kommt und um sagt sei ihm egal
jeder gesellschaft werde ihm gut genug
diese indifferenz stellt moralisch und
politisch gesprochen die größte gefahr
dar
auch wenn sie weit verbreitet ist aus
dem unwillen oder der unfaehigkeit seine
beispiele und seinen umgang zu wählen
und dem unwillen oder der unfaehigkeit
durch urteil zu anderen in beziehung zu
treten entstehen die wirkliche standen
die wirklichen stolpersteine welcher
menschlicher macht nicht beseitigen kann
weil sie nicht von menschlichen oder
menschlich verständliche motiven
verursacht wurden
darin liegt der horror des bösen und
zugleich seiner banalität